Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. My
name is David Flanagan, although you may know
me from across the Internet as Rawkode.
And today, I am your host for another
episode of Custard.
Today, we are joined by Alex Jones and
Alistair Hay, who will be doing their best
to fix clusters broken by the other.
So before we begin, I just wanna say
thank you to Equinix Metal. They provide all
of the hardware that we use for Clustard.
I over provision because it's more fun and
I enjoy it, but we have tons of
cores, tons of RAM, and two very broken
machines for each other to fix. And also
thank you to Teleport who have been supporting
Clustard for a long time now, almost since
the very first episode.
So, you know, appreciate it. There are links
in the description below which will get you
$200 of free credits with Equinix Medal and
some more information on Teleport. So go and
click away and enjoy. But don't click until
after the episode because we've got some clusters
to fix first.
Now my guests are
Alex and Alister. You're now on screen. Hello,
and welcome.
Hey there. Pleasure to be here.
My name is
Alex, as you know. I thought I'd introduce
myself and just say that I'm super excited
because
I think I've got myself into the deep
end, but I'm excited to to sort of
compete in a friendly way against Alistair. So,
yeah, looking forward to it.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
Alright. Yeah. Thanks thanks both. I'm Alistair.
Yeah. Looking forward to,
what would be the the way to say
this, making a fool of myself,
floundering around and mistyping all the commands like
we do when everyone's watching. So looking forward
to getting stuck in and seeing what's in
store for
for us in the episode. Thanks. Well, that's
half the fun. Right?
Like, once it's there's something very weird about
it, but the minute there's a camera on
your face or an audience and sat in
front of you on a bunch of chairs,
it's like everything that you thought you knew
just
disappears.
Some sort of, I don't know,
live
stage effect.
However, you you were on briefly before. Right?
You did
Rawkode Yes. Rawkode
where I set you to all of the
film miserably. So if we've already seen you,
you look stupid, that's fine. Yeah. That's true.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you everyone in the comments.
Feel free to say hello and support. And
remember, your comments are there. You're gonna see
things that we don't. But whenever you see
something that we mess, throw it straight into
the comment section and I will relay that
on to our two contestants today.
We are gonna start
with Alex fixing Alister's cluster.
So if you could please open a session
on Alex Jones control plane one, I will
share my screen and join, and we will
kick things off.
So I should join on my control plane
one? Oh, sorry. Alister. He control plane one.
I was worried there for a minute.
I didn't break that one.
Okay.
Cool. Can you see it? I do indeed.
So I'm hitting join. I'm just joining first
so that I don't flash your IP address
to the world.
Cool. Alright. We can now see everything you
type. Feel free to export your cube config
and take it away. Best of luck.
Yeah.
I I think probably what I'm gonna do
is reverse search on what files have been
modified on the host OS before I do
anything else.
Sneaky sneaky.
Oops. Sorry. It's dasher. That's it.
K. So let's go from top to bottom.
Otherwise, put it into a file.
There's quite a lot of files on this
computer, and I'm going through every single one
of
The hard part is also the machines are
spun up on demand, and everything has been
modified in the last forty eight hours.
Yeah. But it'll be it'll be it'll be
in order. True.
Let's have a look what we get. So
okay. So file parts,
system b. Yeah. Okay. Nothing interesting.
K.
Well, let's see what
sort of key control points to before we
run it.
Let's check if that's your binary.
Looking like someone who has seen an episode
before.
Yeah. I've worked. Yeah. Exactly.
Okay. Great. Or since you've shipped before, either
way, we'll fork. Yeah. And I think I
think it's a combination of both. That's the
r c file.
Okay.
Let's check the aliases.
Okay. I don't think you trusted you, Alistair.
Yeah. Yeah. So the
oops. Saying nothing. Okay.
Let's try and
just see if we can connect it to
the cluster.
Oops. Sorry. It's
keep it complete. Keep
it complete. There we go.
Okay. Let's have a look. Atman.com.
K. So I can see the cluster. That's
great. Let's export that like you did.
Yep. Finished.
Just grab that. Put that in here.
Okay.
Okay. This is the thing here. This one.
Right? Clustered in the default namespace.
Let's
make my life easier. I've only got so
many minutes to live. So let's go on
my other tab. I'm gonna grab web install.
We're gonna web install k nines because I've
got stuff to do.
So I'm gonna do that. Grab that. There
we go.
Web install is a really great project. If
you've used it, they got sorry, webby dot
shell, I think it is. The key works
really hard to make a lot of stuff
compatible
apart from when it doesn't run. You have
to update the export path,
it looks like. Yeah.
So that should be fine. Right?
Here we go. Okay.
Let's jump into this and have a look.
In fact, before we do that, let's just
see and see any of the part the
nodes had
scheduling turned off on them because that's kind
of an easy thing to do.
So there's no schedule on the
worker plane.
That one's got a taint on it.
That one the worker also
has
no schedule slash oops. I don't think that
comes with Kubernetes.
Let's
remove that taint.
Okay.
Oops.
Let's get rid of the case. So let's
remove that taint off of there.
I'm not sure I can leave a spec
object. Oh,
It's
not got a role, but that should be
fine.
I'm not scheduling yet, so let's go and
have a look at what else could be
broken.
CoreDNS running.
Is there a core file?
I'm being overly cautious, but it's sort of
covering the. Is there a core file? Because
sometimes people mess with DNS.
Yep. That's the default core file.
Okay.
K.
Gosh. It doesn't show up very well. Hope
you all can see it. Yeah. It looks
okay. I'm just saved.
And it's v two. Right? It's the image.
Indeed.
Alright.
Let's see what goes wrong.
Okay. So nothing's happening.
Let's have a look the API server.
Okay.
So
failed calling webhook.
Default gates.
This is a warning on the dispatcher.
Let's have a look.
These are the case in part. Okay.
Let's see.
Mission webhooks we've got.
Let's go back and have another look. So
we should have a type. I'm validating. Yeah.
Validating. That's what I want.
Fault takes webhooks on validatingexample.com.
I can just delete this.
I don't need a validator in webhook.
Oh, that hard work. Delete it. I don't
understand.
Yeah. So let's just try and delete this
pod
to see if it will if it will
recreate.
So
the pod's gone.
Have a look what's going on in the
deployment.
I'm
just gonna resize this because I can't quite
see half of the screen. Okay.
It's gonna have replicas. It's a replica set.
So you've got the old one. Just purge
that.
Current replica set.
K. So
we have an issue. Oh, we don't have
any issues. This is trace garbage.
Okay.
Let's let's
go deeper. So
okay. So let's look at what's going on
here. You've got a
bunch of pods here.
This is your I c t l. I
think we can also look at the
current container drilling or current container trying to
schedule.
My server is running.
CTL
steps.
In a.
Alright. Let's go back and figure out what
is going on. So our pod is in
scheduling.
Is there a placement issue? Let's have a
look.
Server.
Okay.
I
need to get a better view of this
log. It's not very useful looking at it
in k nine. It's actually like that.
There we go. I got some stuff coming
out here. That's a while ago.
Request too large.
This is the entire API server log, so
I regret doing that now.
We've we'll be here a little while. So
there we go. So the last stuff we
have is the webhooks, and then we can
see now that we can't schedule.
So if I was to debug this, first
principle is dictate that you probably want to
try and replicate it in a simpler example.
So what we're gonna do is
we are going to grab the simplest pod
on the web, which is the
NGINX example.
We're gonna grab that.
Paste that in.
Oops.
No. Not because
click.
Okay.
Okay. So the deployment creates
so we know that
we know that is working.
Do we? Yes. We do. So is working.
So the actual deployment's being created. It's admitting
it.
We know that Rawkode is being
created,
but we don't have the pods
being scheduled.
Typically,
I would expect to see an issue with
the the pods in a pending phase.
So let's figure out what we've done wrong
or what we can't what's not working here.
Sometimes what can be useful as well is
to look directly at the journal.
Not this time, perhaps.
Let's have a look at x e f
f. Is that right?
Okay.
So we've got our webhook issue here, and
now we're seeing a direct response
from logging.go
on the go restful. Okay. That's not particularly
useful.
So what we can try doing is to
see if
we're getting anything in
directly to the syslog.
Okay.
So this is from Teleport, I think. Yep.
What else we got? We've got
against teleport teleport. Yeah. Nothing really
going to syslog. I've got here we go.
Fail creating default webhook. Yeah. That's not what
I want.
Quite a bind.
Okay.
Let's get
we I mean, we can do
I'm going to and see what's going on,
but I don't really want to have to
do that just yet.
So what else we've got running here? Maybe
we've got something deleting things.
Got the controller manager. So what's responsible for
creating a pod after we have a replica
set?
So I think that we have the
controller manager to start scheduling placement.
What would your inclination be here?
My inclination is that he has changed the
parameters on the API server and disabled the
pod controller.
Okay. Let's have a look.
Oops.
On the controller manager, not the API server.
Sorry. Yeah. Sorry.
What
am I not seeing? Okay. So controllers, you've
got
bootstrapper,
token cleaner rep minus replica set.
Can you put a minus in front of
it? Does that actually emit it? It disables
the replica set controller, which won't create pods.
Yeah. Yeah. I thought let's have a look.
There there is a doc for this, isn't
there? I just wanna check for it.
I thought that the the this it's a
sequence so that the the asterisk wildcard
will be overwritten by the last argument in
the line.
I think that might be how it works.
It's like gets expanded and then everybody Yeah.
In order. Yeah. Okay.
God. What's it called?
Cube. It's not cube, but it keeps the
control manager.
It should this shows how It's the cubit.
The cubit will start to control the manager
as a container. Yeah. It just shows off
now if you do this. Okay. It's not
that It will probably pick it up, that
change, because it's in the manifest file. It
can take up to four But if you
restart it, it speeds it up.
Hey. We have pods.
Yeah. And then we have NGINX, and then
we have the
the new version deployed.
I think think that's it.
We're good? I can't test it. I mean,
I could download the on local host on
port 30,000.
Okay. Okay. Let's do that. So so
let's go to keep control of get pods.
Keep control of port forwards. Oh, you don't
have to port forward. That's a node port
service configured. Oh, okay. Okay. So you can
probably get service curl
localhost
30,000.
Oops. That's yeah.
We have more break,
I think. Okay.
Is the image correct?
Seems so. Yeah. It looks correct.
Maybe the node port's not working. Let's see
where we are.
Actually, before we do that, let's just look
at the
okay. Let's just have to write down.
Let's just do an IP table's flush.
That's any Not even looking at the IP
table. It's just flushing them to hell. Yeah.
I this in production. It always works. No
no no implications of deleting all the IP
table chains.
Okay. Let's flush the IP table rules. Let's
check the service.
So node port
30,000.
Okay. So cluster
IP 30,000 binds to six six six. That
looks kind of malicious.
That is correct. I'm sorry. That is the
real Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Sometimes my key binds don't seem to work.
There is no there's no port on the
on the deployment.
Is that the is that the issue?
Okay. I
I I do some Kubernetes training, and I
always talk about the ports on the the
pod spec, and there is the it doesn't
do anything. That allows you to name a
port. Everything other than that, it's documentation.
There's no We're not need to we're not
need to define the container ports. Nope. It
doesn't do it anything at all.
Anyway.
It's perchless.
YOLO.
Okay.
Anyway.
Yeah. So at the same time, it's not
You need to fix your dash, because the
dash was stolen on image. Okay. Okay. Well,
I'll just I'll just leave it then. Everyone's
gonna do this. Okay. Okay. So that's not
it. Okay.
Let's try that again. Okay. So it's still
blocked.
So there's two reasons for the it may
not be that it's blocked. It could be
that it's time and out, and it could
be the cluster of the application speaks to
a Postgres service. It could be that Postgres
doesn't happen. Okay. Okay. I I don't know
enough about the application. That's true. It's Postgres
running as a stateful set.
I can sort of see it.
You're managing, like, running PG bouncer on this,
are you?
No. App info. No. App info. I should
know this.
I thought I told you it's installed.
I thought that's
I considered doing this, but I thought it
was too evil.
Okay.
Okay. So not PG bouncer. So we could
try
and figure out what is going on. Now,
firstly, let's just check that everything's good with
curl.
Yeah. So we've got we've got curl working.
We could then also then try to see
if it's an issue with the node port.
So if we do get the service and
we do a direct port forward
and we put that in background
actually, I might live to regret that. I
can't open multiple terminals up here, can I,
very easily? Is that okay if I connect
you in another session? Or Yeah. Go. Feel
free. Okay. I'll just do that so that
I'll open up the session briefly, and then
I'll close it again. I'm just gonna validate
what's going on here. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. So I've been mocked in the comments
anyway from Russell who's saying, you could check
the application logs.
But, unfortunately, I've been meaning to add logging
for the application for for many, many Yeah.
I didn't I didn't see any logs.
I should think that. I should
Let's
go and have a look.
I don't see.
So
this port for that locate six six six.
In another tab, I'm just gonna complete curl
that.
Yes. It's still not working. Okay.
So let's think about what's going on. We
can't see anything coming out of the application.
Well, if you do a curl with a
for both logging, does it show connection accepted
or connection pending?
Let's have a look.
K.
Looks like
A curl dash v should show
isn't it? That's just trace?
You can just trace it. Yeah.
Yeah. It's it looks like it's hanging.
What's going on here? Hang on. What's what
is this garbage?
Okay. Cluster. Not garbage. No. No. No. No.
No. I
I just see I'm I'm just I'll show
you what I was looking at, actually.
It's going
local host.
I think it's 30,000 there.
So we're seeing that it's connection refused. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. 100% refused.
So
we you know, I again, I I I
kinda work from what I know, and I
think that's kind of a good strategy in
life, generally. And so I would pretty validate
this by on my NGINX deployment,
opening up that node port because what we
can determine from that is, has it been
broken on the entire machine, or is it
specific to this deployment? So where did our
engine x go? I didn't roll out a
didn't roll out a service with that.
I'm gonna have
shamelessly steal one. So glamorously on the other
side of the page, what I'm doing is
doing Kubernetes..i0
and just grabbing the default deployment
and service.
You could just keep control exposed as a
command as well.
Do you know what? I have probably used
that
four times in my life. Let's do it.
I I honestly I never ever use it.
Let's have a look. So let's see if
the API is in the same. So keep
control exposed as an example.
Expose,
rep a cassette. Right? What's what's RC there?
Okay. Port eight. Alright. Let's try that.
Assuming that RC is oh, yeah. Replication controller.
Okay. So let's do deployment.
And the name might think for us. Let's
just double check.
Yep. Was engine x deployment. Okay.
Next deployment.
And I think
Target port is six six six, and the
port is I don't know. I'm just checking
I was just checking my NGINX example so
I can validate whether it's another issue. Hold
on. I'm just checking what port it comes
on. Think it's 80, isn't it? Port 80.
Oh, it's gonna be a screen. Come on.
Yeah. Target port.
Your screen's wider than mine. Okay. Let's go
with that.
Okay.
Let's now
curl it.
Little v.
Okay. So we've got connection refused to
that.
You just target Porsche on on your exposed.
That should be 80.
Oh, I'm sorry. Yes. You're right.
And yeah. Yeah.
Chicken and egg problem.
K.
I
prefer it locally if it wasn't bound to
the h p p h p port.
Okay. Interesting.
So if I have that right, what that
tells me is that I can't no ports
aren't working
in the cluster.
What I can do to verify that, again,
is to
do a port forward and check
if the so then I'll get
I've seen the service type.
It's just IP right now. Wanted to get
a report, didn't I?
Okay. I've done that slightly incorrectly.
Okay.
Oh, now your now your node port is
32,000
something.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Into it. Oh, yeah. And I'm also
on the wrong it's it's not targeting the
wrong port on the
on the deployment.
So you get when you do something in
a rush.
I think the target port's necessary anymore, is
it? I could delete that. Well, the port
is a service port for cluster IP. The
target port defaults to the normal port, and
the target port could be different.
So services are fun.
Yeah.
There we go. That should be correct.
Can you run cube control get s v
c comma e p?
I like to call that there. The Which
sorry. Which one? Delete the
slash into comma e p. E
p. Uh-huh. For endpoint. Yeah. There
we go. It looks good. Yeah. It should
it should be working. I like that. Yeah.
Okay.
So that's been blocked as well.
Okay. No. You used the wrong port again.
Remember, it's 632428.
3 2 4 2 8. But
still blocked. Hanging as well. Okay.
We'd already looks I've already dumped the table.
It's not gonna be that.
Could be this c n I. Let's think
about that maybe, sort of.
It could be let's have a look at
host name. Let's look at
AC hosts.
Local host is set.
You wanna try it from a worker node?
We could do that. Yep. Let's so shall
I do I'll I'll open a worker node
session, and you can join that one. Is
that what you Yeah. Want you to Okay.
So let me just open one. Okay.
Okay. So
Just try curl local host C2428.
Hey. How did you configure cube control in
that?
On this node? Yeah.
We just exported it very quickly. But there's
no
there shouldn't be an admin.com from that machine.
Oh,
you're using a Kubler service account. Right. Okay.
That's okay, isn't it? Yeah. Sure. It's not
Oh, so oh, that sounds like something rules,
is it? I mean, I can't You could
could create these things for sure, so why
not?
So, yeah, try the current local host 32428.
Just because I I need to know.
3248,
was it? 428. Yeah.
There you go. Okay. It works there. So
try the try 30,000?
It's been set on that machine.
No. There's still something broken with that one.
But your engine x one did work.
Interesting.
Okay.
So
I'm just thinking if we go
let's have a look what's actually
Got about fifteen minutes left.
Okay. Time goes quick, doesn't it?
Alex has dropped a lot a lot of
truth bombs on us. A lot of things
I'd never thought to look at. Yeah. Your
camera's gone off. Haven't fixed it yet.
Haven't fixed it yet. So we'll we'll see.
I mean, it could be a proxy configuration.
It could be I p six being forced.
I don't know. It could be a lot
of different things. Can you prod your camera,
Alex?
I think it's Sorry. Yeah. This is what
I'm talking about, my camera. Sorry. Let's
let's try echo. Let's do an env. Is
it an HP proxy?
Mean, probably not.
Nope. That's not an echo now.
Let's just do Could be That
would be mean.
Yeah. It could be.
Then I'd be really, really stuck.
So just looking.
Yeah. I mean, I don't see anything that
is currently active on those.
What else can I do? I'm trying to
think proactively. Rogue processes under PSUX
would be what I started to do.
I could
oh, that is htop, isn't it?
What we got here?
The Chrome process.
Macron Taproot.
What's we got?
Wonder if it's a
what's that?
That's
picking up on two thing. Okay.
I don't see anything that stands out.
That is a beefy machine. Yeah. 48 cores
of power
It's 62 gig of RAM.
That's the rule.
It's what you need for your bad code
application, isn't it? Yeah. For a Rust application
that takes about 36 bytes of RAM. I
didn't really think about this, but it could
be done in Cilium, couldn't it? It could
be a it could be a
Yeah. It could a network policy. It could
be a yeah. Could be a network policy.
Let me just switch. Are you can you
switch back to other computers just because I
can change it? Okay. Yep. It's gone. K.
Nice. Off you go.
No cost to wide network policies. Okay. Damn.
Thought that was gonna be it. Well, there
are three policies. There's cost to wide network
policies, there's still a network policies, and then
there's networking v one network policy.
Okay. No network policies.
And what about network and v one network
policy?
You see that?
I don't see that here.
Egress NAT policies endpoints.
Well, just run kubectl get net net poll.
Yeah. They're not custom resources. So Yeah. There
we go.
Okay. I don't think it allows all, like,
at the scrape.
I was just gonna have a look. I
think I could just delete that.
Yeah. There we go. Allowing this traffic none.
Yeah.
Yeah. It doesn't allow any ingress to the
cluster.
Yeah. It deletes.
K.
And I was gonna have you looking for
eBPF probes as well. Oh, that that's not
work. How mean do you think I am?
Yeah.
Okay. That affects your current local host 30,000?
I'm just gonna have a look. What was
it again? It was thirty
thirty thousand.
No. It's
still sitting.
Okay.
But that that oh, no. Look. That's Postgres
now waiting because we got we got headers.
Do have any logs from this?
Okay. No logs.
Postgres will have logs.
But, yeah, cluster point.
Not in the Postgres cluster.
Let's see logs there.
Okay. Let's see if the service has been
deleted.
It points to the
The ports look funny, though. Right?
Ports.
Can you see that?
Zero. Data is zero.
Oh, no. That's okay. Yeah. It's okay.
And CA will just throw me off on
the k nine. Yeah. I think it should
show zero when it's going to the same
port.
Why not just Yeah.
Why not just show nothing on? Or sort
of yeah. I don't know. I've spotted that
in the past. I don't know. I don't
know. Maybe it's not that. I mean, I
don't know what the passwords are, so I
can't tell if you've done if you changed
that.
I'll assume you weren't enough because that would
be unsolved. It says the password was there,
Postgres password.
Yeah. It's hard to put it on the
app. I I I think that's correct. Okay.
Okay.
Let's have a look.
So it got a little it's it's running.
It's running on it's bound to an interface
that is bound to
that doesn't matter there. That's inside the pod.
That's just the library to check.
What else we got?
Yeah. I I think Postgres is running. I
can't really tell. I mean, I can install
p s equal, and we can start playing
with it, I guess, with the next thing.
We've only got a few minutes.
There's no hints in the hints directory. So
you can ask for him.
Okay.
What's for him? I'll for a first hint.
Can I can I get a lifeline?
It's it's DNS.
Oh, it's DNS. Oh, I thought I looked
at the core file.
Back to it. We go oversite. There's an
oversight.
Yeah. It's not that. Yeah. That looks okay.
Yeah. That's fine.
Let's have a look at your proxy.
It looks like there is a good proxy
because it's a silly and cluster with your
proxy. Yes. Proxy running.
I kinda haven't used
I haven't really used how to say the
inverse DNS.
Let have a look.
Is there a resource that you configure it
as a file?
Let's have a look. We can figure out
how isn't responsible for DNS.
Let's have a look. So disable DNS. Let's
have a look at host DNS.
There were no cellular network policies. We still
have l seven DNS awareness, but we didn't
I thought I thought we could do local
DNS with Cilium or something like that or,
you know, DNS based rules. You can if
you use that Cilium local redirect policy, but
I don't think we've seen any when we
looked at k nines earlier. Okay. Well, let's
let's try something else. So if I spin
up a quick
pod in the cluster, and I could try
and use some network tools
to do an s already.
Should give you the to
app.
That's do they have apps in it? Yeah.
It's
a point to I mean,
by default.
It's had I mean, well, unlike Ubuntu, this
has CVEs in. Ubuntu is the only distribution
of Linux on zero c major CVEs,
criticals, apparently.
Whereas NGINX is the one that always comes
up. I should just check this installed.
Maybe Okay. App update first.
Oh.
Okay.
So the
so this part itself can't
yes. It's Yeah. They're doing it. That's the
cost of a ton. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
K. Let's look at what's going on with
core DNS.
Okay. Let's go to the
logs,
settings.
I don't think there's anything you can really
tweak in there. I think it's just the
core file.
Abilities
Let me ask you a question, Alistair.
Should we be looking on the worker?
Yes. Yeah. I think I know what this
is, but I'm gonna give Alex
Let's go and have a look at the
worker then and see what's going on.
Okay.
Everyone's the worker.
Let's do
let's see if we can do any kind
of NS lookup.
I'm just thinking whether
whether it's gonna be something you've done at
the host level,
you know, like
no. We've still got we've got local DNS
on the host.
Okay.
Let's try
I'm trying to think here.
Coming from the
one of the pods running from this particular
node.
So there's a template setting for DNS configuration,
which might be Oh, right. Okay.
And the kibble kibble config in the manifests.
You're need to go to Varlib kubelet, probably.
And
then config dot YAML.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So the cluster name is fine.
Cluster DNS,
is that actually set to the IP address
of the static parts for core DNS?
I'm not sure. I think that's been modified.
I don't think it should be 1010.
I don't need to restart this, do I?
So just auto restart?
I think you're gonna have to kick some
pods,
I think. Right?
Because the DNS configuration
is injected into the sandbox, so you'll probably
have to delete the cluster pod for the
DNS to do it.
Okay.
And that's assuming he's not changed the default
cluster DNS policy.
I couldn't see in the config.
I feel like I didn't put enough breaks
in and mind that. I think I need
to things.
Oh, well, we got through quite a few.
Let's see whether that's worked.
Nice.
Job done. We have v two video in
there. Well,
lots of help from you, David. So thank
you.
Well done. That was fun. Well done.
Those those were all things that I've fixed
in the past
on the cluster.
So I tried to keep them real.
Awesome. Interesting. My favorite one is,
I like the I like the net policy.
I think that was quite funny because you
can just look at that and, oh, it's
fine. You know?
I think that's the the thing about network
policies. Right? It's like there's
so much defaulting going on that they passed
the eyeball test when they do literally nothing.
And then what you have to really you
gotta really understand that actually they they block
all by default. You
need to start opening things up. Yeah.
And then the DNS change with the eyeball.
It's like 10 dot 10 passes the eyeball
test. I've just seen enough shit that I
know that that's not right. That's
a magic IP as well because it's set
to the same as the service is set
to. And if it's not right or one
of them has been changed or something, then
things get weird. There
we go. I have to I have to
prefix
this as if we go into it. Mine
was way too hard to begin with. Right?
Way too hard. It was causing David some
headaches, like because I kept asking to restart
the computer server. So I I think I've
gone one away now. So I think you
might end up solving it in about thirty
seconds. So if that's the case, I apologize.
Sorry. You could just add more Blake's while
he's faxing. Like okay. Yeah. That is true.
I'm just going in. Live action clustered breaker.
Red team, blue team. Yeah.
That'd be fun, wouldn't it?
Alright. Well, awesome work, Alex.
You finished under time. You got everything working,
and we've seen some cool breaks along the
way. So thank you, Alistair. Alistair, do you
wanna open up a session on
Alex Jones control plane one? Let me know
when you've done it. I'll join it, and
we'll check over.
Okay.
Yes.
Control plane one.
Join that session.
Okay. Give me a sec.
It's
just hanging, I think.
Yeah. I said on the chat saying
that was great. Alex is still calm while
debugging. Not only were you calm, like, were
verbalizing your thought process. Like, we I I
just I was just sitting back and joined.
Like, I didn't have to do anything. Thank
you. If as a word of advice, when
people do that in interviews, it's really helpful
for interviewers. You know? If you're doing a
coding interview and you don't feel you feel
really stressed or nervous, just vocalize it because
I actually I find it helps me stay
calm.
Can you not connect, Alistair?
Yes.
I'm in now. It took a long time.
I'm sure that's a good sign. I'm sure
that is Everything's very slow. Oh, no.
You should have seen the sadistic people I
work with. You should have seen the things
they were suggesting I do. I have held
back.
Well, we had a nice welcome message as
we
approached.
So
Well, I'm I'm doing the same, Alex. Sorry.
Sorry. You're doing that. No. K nine s
first.
But it's being very slow,
which is filling me with thread.
So
we we have some hose breaks, I assume.
I'm just gonna grab a glass of water.
Alright.
It is doing it, but it is slow.
So Give that a second. Running h top
after this and see if we
Yeah. Maybe I give you one of the
machines with one VCP here.
Okay. What does that say? It's telling you
to source that mail.
Yeah. Okay.
There's nothing more annoying than you're on a
really slow machine.
Gosh. No. You got a nice machine too.
But it's likely that any performance degradation you're
seeing is intentional.
Good luck.
Okay.
At least you could taste. Thing.
Which one is it? E f minus h.
Have we got a full disc?
No.
Okay.
Can I ask a question? I I is
it another part which is why you're doing
so we'd throw them off?
Sorry. Say that again? Say again. I was
wondering if you're okay if I ask questions,
or is it gonna throw you off whilst
you're doing this? I just was wondering why
would that be your default go to? Why
would the disk being full, why do you
think that will slow down the CPU?
Well, it just slows everything down.
From from from his from my past experience,
I don't I don't really
know the
ins and outs of it. But when I've
when I've SSHed onto a machine, which is
full,
it's usually pretty slow.
Normally, because all the processes are trying to
write logs, and they can't and you get
lockups. But I think they're okay. There are
I mean, there is some rules because there's
one of them has no saturation attack. So
We should it's largely through swapping as well.
Yeah. Just a problem. So I'll send them
I think it's not there now.
Is it gone?
I don't know. What what now? It's there.
I know. It's it's oh, it's It's slow.
Guys, very slow.
Okay.
Why is it slow?
What's happening?
Nothing
showing as
using
too much CPU.
In fact, this command is the slowest one.
Oh my god.
I mean, all you need to do is
update v one to v two. It doesn't
matter if it's slow, really.
Give
oh
my god. Mistype.
And
it's admin.com,
isn't it? It is indeed.
I didn't do my export. He doesn't source
the
yeah. I've
gotta fill this time with talk, and I
have no chat. So
okay.
Alright.
What do we have?
Unable to connect.
Of course. We have no context, no cluster,
no API server potentially.
Okay.
So
Not the best amount to test the APIs
ever. I've gotta say. Quit.
K nine is quite heavy, isn't it? There's
quite a few calls.
Yeah. I feel like you're trying to give
me a hint, but I'm too stupid to
know what it means.
I can give you a hint if you
would like. Because this might if you don't
know this, it might be quite difficult.
Yeah. Go for it.
Oh, come on. It's too early for that.
Me just
say this. The the the speed
slowdown is not gonna impede you, like David
said. That's not gonna stop you from doing
what you're trying to do.
If you're worried about
slow down,
like,
best CTL
would be something I start exploring.
Yeah.
We don't need that. We can do this.
Come on. Yeah.
Let's have a look.
Container d is not running.
We don't need Container d.
So the qubits in the crash loop.
Dynamic file. Dynamic.
It suddenly got really hot in here.
I'm just gonna turn the heating off. Alexa,
turn off the office floor. Oh, actually hot.
Alright. I thought you were just nervous and
sweating.
Oh, no. No. The temperature is it? It's
only 22.
But I only
updated
your Alexa, so it's increasing the temperature in
your office.
Next level clustered.
Yeah.
Would that be causing it to be super
slow? Probably not.
I mean, if we're seeing a slowdown like
this without
CPUs and RAM being hammered,
my immediate thing is I I mean, I
would wanna start looking at this control and
see maybe modify the table to see if
it is running processes under nice, like, control
groups for random
system processes.
That for CPU.
Is it That guy.
Mean, it should all be lowercase, but just
okay. Yeah.
Mine is alright. Yeah.
Max percent 25.
Or CPU.
So it could be it depends how it's
been. Right? So you could have processed these
changes to some sort of fail. In which
case, you could try just running
you you could try resetting
all these things.
But, yeah, that pair of CPU 10 max
percent.
I I don't know if that's just normal
or we're just looking at it under the
context of things being broken, but I would
maybe change it.
How do you set one?
MSW?
No.
Well, just do sys control dash dash system.
Does that reset them? I think so. So
no graphic for CPU again?
Still very slow.
Alright.
Is that something we should be looking at,
Alex, that pair of CPU time max percent,
or is that a redhead? Yeah. That that
has not been modified. Okay. That's not because
of the speed.
What command was that?
Message.
D message. Alright.
Okay.
I mean, that's going very low level.
Yeah.
Yeah. I have literally no idea.
Alright. I would just
kill this machine from the auto scanning group,
and it would come back to life.
Alright. Let's let's do some
searching. Alright? So
alright. Or you can just keep typing d
message.
Sorry. I didn't know what was happening.
That was fun.
I don't know. I
alright. Maybe not then.
Mhmm.
What have you done? Let me see.
Well, processes look alright.
The slowness
I mean,
yeah, the the typing
speed is a little slow. Right?
Mhmm. What if we
oh, I wanna see if we can actually
cause the course to actually do some work
because
yeah.
Alex has been mean, hasn't he?
I've done far fewer fit things than you
have.
You
were up over, I think, five or six
different things. So you had me running through
hoops, jumping through hoops.
Alright. We'll take a hand then. I feel
like you've disabled some of the CPUs,
maybe constrained the IOPS over this.
But I to be honest, I'm not sure
how to check.
If you were physically in front of the
machine
typing on the terminal, you wouldn't see this
latency.
Okay.
So some
may Just to slightly speed this up, you're
still gonna have to work out the answer,
but it it's
using traffic control.
The TC control. Which is a program.
We've all ever seen traffic control once on
clustered.
Yeah. It's pretty nice, and not a lot
of people use it.
Where's its comp?
It doesn't have one.
Oh, no.
It's everywhere.
Run PC commands and you apply
constraint.
We've seen that in the past where one
person applied a 50% network packet drop on
all is OTCP
traffic.
Wow. That's mean.
Also breaks teleport,
apparently.
Less
constraint.
I'm gonna Google it.
Me too.
Traffic control.
Alright. So we have some sort of queuing
discipline.
We have filters
for
going to just
how do we list all those traffic control
modifications?
That's what I wanna know.
If that's even possible.
Qdesk seems to be the command they mentioned
them more.
There you go.
So we have a limit thousand delay one
point five seconds and a limit thousand delay
five hundred millisecond
applied
to east zero and east one.
Okay.
I don't know how to delete them.
You can just live with it.
You could just live with it. Mean Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
You're getting, like, the experience of running a
Pentium four six five or, like, you know,
early nineties computers. Yes.
From half the country away
before my time.
I mean, I I don't know if I
should be allowed to make up commands. I
I'm not feeling brave.
Okay. Let's just Google it. I guess it's
what we do when we talk to the
answer to something. So
how do we remove
What was it called? And So you can
do a t c q dash del dev
dev
root. Right? So let's modify that
to try and match those two rules that
we have there. So q dash del
dev probably stays dev, but the dev in
uppercase is probably
EF0 and EF1. E F 0. Wanna run
it for those two, I think. Okay.
And if we lose access to Teleport, we'll
just go to the pub and have a
beer.
Well, I set it to a thousand seconds
then.
Alright.
Try the Oh my god. It's so quick.
Yay.
Oh, I feel like a running arch there.
No?
There we go. It's so quick.
I've never seen somebody so happy.
Oh,
it's so good. Right. There you go, DJ.
Right. Yes.
That
was fun.
Okay.
These are the cubelet logs.
What happens if you try and keep control
get nodes? Do we just have no API
server?
The Kubelet is crashing.
You don't need a Kubelet for an API
server.
Alright. Probably.
Yeah.
This one, CTL.
No.
Status.
Okay. No.
Inactive and dead.
Yes.
Do enable that session error,
and that will start with the.
Yeah. Look.
Hey. He's doing stuff.
Something not found.
Versatile part. Let's see.
Okay.
You didn't trust cube control, did you? Oh.
Fine.
So that is a binary.
It's a go binary.
Try control
version.
I'll leave it all that.
Yeah.
I was gonna say I should It's just
the one.
So you did a fail on the actual
binary, but try to type your control without
the which.
It may not you may not be executing
the binary.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
That
was that was last year originally. That's been
turned out.
That's Control delete all namespaces.
Shift code tag. Shift all alpha echo.
Terminal echo. Okay.
Think you have a pretty broken cluster right
now.
Yep.
In fact, I think it's in worse shape
than it was when you started.
Oh, yeah.
But you can you can unalias. You can
re alias kube control.
Is it unalias?
I I will just say I will just
alias kube control back to slash bin slash
kubectl, then it will work properly. I'm alias.
Sorry. Need to give you a just to
give you a hint because we're kinda
Yeah. There you go.
Meow.
Really, it's a cat meow.
Thanks.
I like that one. That was nice.
Yeah. I mean, we don't need the emissary,
so I'm not terribly fast for that. So
you definitely use cube control lease.
Cube node leases. We've we've made we should
be alright with that. As
long as you don't need to
get a new one. Alright. Just
gonna check the event.
We have lost the worker node as well.
You wanna open a session on the worker?
Or Yeah.
Yeah.
You don't have to fix the worker. I'm
just throwing it out there.
Has he done the same on this one?
Yeah.
Yeah. You can just schedule on a control
plan if you want.
I'm still on the same frame. It's just
so fun.
I will leave that.
If I just remove the no schedule on
the control on the
Yep. Control plane, does that do it? It
doesn't do.
So edit node.
Yep.
No.
Shit.
Capital
n, capital f on the node schedule.
Just get rid of them. Yeah. Yep.
Oh, yeah. They ate the wrong node.
Delete one of your nodes.
You
have node nodes. You can either use node
space or or slash, but you can't use.
Node nodes. Node nodes.
Alrighty.
That was aggressive.
I wanna move him off that note. So
I mean, a card that would have been
fine, but, I mean, that's Yeah.
You can control c that. You don't need
to wait for the second half of all
that crap.
Cluster is not scheduled. Add a add a
dash of white just to confirm where where.
Yeah.
Control point. There we go. Yeah. And because
the postgres is a stateful set, might wanna
delete whatever force and just
because in fact, people start running, it will
never do a status check.
I dashed the I
don't think you need the grace period anymore,
but
No. I don't think so. Conditioned.
So
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah. So that that kubelet is not healthy,
which is why we've got stuck in terminating.
Because the would never check-in to see it.
It's actually gone. Yeah.
It's healthy, funny.
WD Fortnite chair.
I know. Can't stand the one.
It is very old.
The canine's.
That's
why he's got the loud keyboard, so you
can't hear the chair. You can't hear the
chair.
Doesn't have any logs. It has no logs.
Is it running v one or v two?
Did you update the v one?
I did update it. It's still v one.
Not changed.
Okay. It's not to create a replica set.
Just check I changed that. No. Oh. Something.
Yeah. I didn't think I changed it.
I forgot. Maybe I did.
Did I edit the pod? I did the
pod. That's why.
Pod specs are immutable except for the image.
Yeah.
I guess, every bit almost is the point.
Mean, that is v two.
Alright.
So that is done? What was it?
Three
Sorry.
No.
Of course.
So you're getting headers. That's Yep.
Yeah.
So
network oh, just put Postgres is running. Yeah.
May not have initialized, actually.
Okay. Yeah. It has.
Run get pod service endpoint.
I don't think I don't know why people
don't run that more. I don't know why
I don't get the AI inside.
I just You don't like it? No.
I hate too much. I
don't think this is something that I've done.
This is exciting.
I think you just nervous.
Well, actually, there's there's a weird thing that
I've never really gotten to the bottom of
where the node ports don't work on the
control plane sometimes,
and you have to do it on the
worker node. But here, it should definitely work.
We'll try again.
Well Yeah.
I
know it's it's simple to know to do
do all that stuff.
Well, I'll just check these as well.
No.
You press not policies.
Endpoints.
What was the other one? Let's see the
network policy now.
Okay.
So
we're good.
Control c.
Okay. So pod's running. Postgres is running, but
networking
IP table?
Yeah.
No
rejections. I don't see anything.
I don't really know what I'm looking at.
Some firewall
pulls.
Alright. Sorry.
That will keeps Kubernetes running.
Yeah.
That looks suspicious.
You see the drops?
The
bottom. Yeah.
We're blocking He's commented them for us.
So kind.
Drop all anywhere anywhere.
Yeah. It's dropping it's dropping all packets where
the source haven't been marked. As as local
host. Yeah.
I think. Sometimes I read these wrong, but
I I would flush them out. Just go
there.
What is it? Dash dot capital f.
And then run dash l again just to
yeah. That's a.
Nice. Well done.
That
was pretty mean.
I've gotta see what the tweet is.
What's the tweet?
Productivity does not determine your value. You have
value in just being you.
Yeah. I mean, we don't fill up the
website much anymore because we just rely on
curls.
You know what I mean? The downside is
people don't get to see me back. But
yeah. Those are those are pretty harsh breaks,
I think. The traffic control one was particularly
mean. Like, I don't think we'd ever have
got that. Like, if you had I had
just slipped with it. Yeah.
But We
as we said, I I I scaled it
back because it you know, as you said
before, like, sometimes you don't know what a
good level is to do. Like, it was
actually doing a seg fault every five minutes,
and that just felt, like, really mean. So
we're not doing that anymore.
I mean, it's tough. Right? Because he he
never it's hard to understand the experience the
other person brings like there are you could
do two breaks and someone never finds them.
But if you get the right person that
knows what they're looking for, then you need
20 breaks. Like it's just it's a complete
game of cat and mouse and as again,
it's not about the fixing and it's not
about how quickly you do it or how
sneaky you are with the breaks. It's just
about getting two smart people who know what
they're doing and seeing how they handle and
debug a situation. I think, to me, that's
always the most valuable thing about what we're
doing here. And I
really liked
you know, we both approached the the the
breaks at different layers, which was quite cool.
You know, you were doing them more in
the kind of case and config, and I
was just using some more of the Linux
capabilities. I think it's quite a nice overlap
to to explore.
Yeah. I I pretty much never run Kubernetes
in production. Actually, the control plane because I've
always used managed. So for me, it was
like, I'm just gonna break it in, like,
user space almost as much as I can
and things that I actually have control over.
I mean, saying that, you have disabled the
replica set controller.
Yeah. Okay. That one's just
because I hate the. I always fail to
look there. And I'm like, nothing's happening. And
it's usually an admission, a validate workbook or
a mutate workbook fail or something. And it
just, like, stops in that layer and disappears.
Nobody
ever looks in that file or at the
controls. I don't think most people know that
you can disable individual controls with a controller
manager. I think it's always me that kinda
really points that one out. And, it's just
because I've seen stuff on cluster.
We've we've seen a lot of these things.
The other one, which I I felt hilarious.
I can't remember when it was, but maybe
about a year ago. Someone just set the
deployment to pause and
it just doesn't roll out any new pods.
But if you don't know that that's there,
you just you never find it. It's just
it's just the Nothing in the logs. Why
it's strange to do this? Yeah. Yeah. It's
it's like, oh, you can pause the deployment
and then you have to explain again what's
actually this whole rule out command and you
can finish this stuff.
It's just there's so many different parts of
the Kubernetes API. Nobody could very unlikely nobody
could know them all. And again, it's just
to get people with different backgrounds as you
know.
This was awesome. Thank you both for for
taking time. I know this could be quite
stressful, so I really appreciate you both breaking
clusters and fixing them live on the stream.
Oh, thank you for having me.
Any last words before we we say goodbye
to our audience for today?
I think just to say that this is
awesome. We've I've certainly enjoyed it. I I
I I think as well. It was very
educational.
I think I learned a lot as well,
and, you know, it's great to have you
as the host, David. So thank you, and
please keep doing it because I know I'll
be watching.
Thank you very much. Yeah. Shout out to
everyone watching. Get involved if you can.
Reach out to David, I guess.
Yeah. Are you planning to carry on these?
I know at one point you were struggling
to find people to come on. It's hard
to find victims. I mean, contestants.
So
It it was less bad than I thought.
I'll just leave that with everyone. Well, this
is the thing. Right? It's like there.
I I know both of you. I know
you're both incredibly smart. You're both very,
very aware with Kubernetes,
but it's intimidating.
Right? You have to be very vulnerable to
set on a livestream and do something like
this. And it's like,
you know, so it's difficult to find people
that are willing to make themselves that vulnerable
and and do this. And I would love
to be able to encourage more people to
do it, but I don't want people to
be uncomfortable either. So it's like, you know,
I'll I will continue to do a cluster
for as long as I can convince you
two and others to come on and join
me into it. And, you know, when I
can, I'm happy to be the one that
looks silly. So, you know, if you just
wanna break a cluster and watch me laugh
and laugh at me try to fix it,
I'm I'm happy to do that too. Let's
let's we'll do that all day. Anyway,
thank you both again. Absolute pleasure too. Very
sneaky breaks, and best of luck for that.
Well done for fixing them, and I'll see
you both again next time. Thank you. Thank
you. Bye bye.